[Music]
growing up in Montana I feel like I had
kind of a special opportunity just to be
outside a lot that's kind of where a lot
of wildlife started for me that dies out
and a lot of kids and for me it just
continued all right guys finished up
beer Dan this little guy hasn't been
named yet my name is Wesley Larson I'm a
master's student working in wildlife
conservation and then uh some circles
I'm known as brisket when I first
started deciding that I should get into
the wildlife field I found dr. Tom Smith
at BYU I started by working with polar
bears on Alaska's North Slope and then
that kind of transition into some black
bear work down here in Utah in Bryce
Canyon Bryce Canyon like other national
parks that do have bears they've had a
kind of a history with with visitor
conflict and with bears that maybe are
getting into campsite so what we're
doing is we're tracking the Bears to
learn what habitats they're using just
to see what the park could do better to
make it easier for visitors to avoid
bears what we're doing is we're fitting
black bears with GPS collars and then
I'll go into the den with the bear to
inject it with some drugs the bear then
falls asleep I can pull it out and you
know just give it a full checkup it's
probably the most scary thing we do just
because bears wake up sometimes they're
really unhappy to see us stay hey snake
get back
hey stay denim I have had to crawl up
trees after bears it's it's an
interesting job for sure people do have
this knee-jerk reaction to see an animal
that's sedated or an animal that's
wearing a collar and think that you know
it might be being hurt and the thing
that they don't realize is that we
really care about these animals probably
more than just about anyone getting out
into the wilderness and and having these
kind of experiences helps you understand
that we depend on wildlife and wildlife
depends on us and that's really what
conservation is all about giving the
space and their respect to these animals
that they deserve and really learning as
much about them as we can
you